[Music]
hello everyone my name is Rajesh Mishra
I'm an engineering lead on the GCE team
doing control plane work I'm joined here
by my colleague because hi everyone I am
Vikas yea though I am an engineer on GCP
and I support the storage solution for
GCE so what we plan to cover is how we
design our control plane to be highly
available so let's let's get started so
before we get started let's talk about
control plane at a very high low high
level so we have an extremely simplified
version from a customer standpoint so
what you see over here what it takes to
orchestrate an API that you submit
against our control plane so I've picked
a canonical example of submitting an
instance creation request so that API we
orchestrate that API that API has many
many steps to be performed so I I just
listed some few of the steps we need to
check the permission we need to check
the org policy quota so on and so forth
any one of these steps could fail so and
you can imagine control plane with many
projects many resources that we manage
many API so that we need to process they
we need to process and remember where we
are exactly
and so we can recover our failures
and since this talk is about the
availability let's define what's an
availability so s-sorry
reliability workbook defines
availability as an uptime of a software
service and the way we calculate our
availability is by accumulating all all
the unavailable periods of downtime or
or some window of time so as an example
for nine employees your service was
unavailable over a thirty day for four
point three minutes and so on so forth
there are a couple dimensions to
availability for a GC system the we
em-up time availability this is nothing
but your VMs our program the network's
being configured your PD is configured
and all all the other stuff has been
programmed by the control plane and your
in your resources are now serving
traffic live traffic that we call VM up
time availability just to draw some
distinction we have control plane
availability which is basically an
on-demand control plane programming that
happens we are one of our REST API s--
and at a very high level the control
plane programming centers around three
key resources the we M the virtual
machines the PDS and any kind of network
access you configure and there are many
more resources of course and I haven't
listed them so it's important to
remember the distinction about these two
availability things the first one is
live traffic serving paths the second is
control pads
we're so proud of the availability work
we have done that we published we have
published as a lay four VM uptime so
four VMs that leverage our multiple
region so for example VMs placed in two
or more zones in a region or it could be
split cross region one can expect an
aggregate uptime availability of four
nines and this would be with no loss of
external connectivity or access to
persistent disk most importantly this
will be without any kind of downtime and
will be transparent even if we carry out
any kind of hosts maintenance so if you
have to carry out any kind of security
patches will do that transparently by
live migrating your VMs and in most
cases you won't notice that so in the
previous slide the security patches we
are talking about is the underlying
system on top of which the VMS are on
and we do live migration when we are
patching the hosts on which the VM run
so while I talked about the VM uptime
availability we we don't have an SLA
that we published for our control plane
but the internal work we have done we're
very proud of what we achieve what we
have achieved
we are the designs that we have that
we'll talk rest of the presentation on
on our control plane availability so as
you guys now sorry before we get started
I need to introduce some key concepts
before we're that are important in the
VM of that are important in our control
plane so as you guys now we serve 17
regions globally each regions can have
multiple zones
at least three or more and they're
spread globally regions are connected to
extremely fast network and highly
available network so any given region
will have at least multiple redundant
network paths which is as Brad kalter
pointed out earlier this morning it's a
pretty key point of Google cloud
platform the rest of the presentation
we're going to talk through some of the
design points that has worked really
well as we work to offer a highly
available control plane and these are
these are this is the system that offers
all the API we serve so I need to
introduce some key building block
foundations on before we get started so
GC resources this is a GC resource data
model we resources like we M's and disks
are zonal resources sub networks static
IPS regional disks these are shared
resources but they're shared across
within a region global resources and the
most important ones are images snapshots
and instance template they're shared
across globally by all the regions so
you can imagine this in a very
object-oriented sense you have a
hierarchical access pattern and we'll
talk through this will refer to this
data model as we explain the kind of
choices we made to build a highly
available control plane so because you
should just jump in as yeah I want to
spend some more time here so we have a
concept of resources which are available
globally so what that means is if you
have instance template which you want to
use to launch VMs in multi
regions you to define it only once and
it will be available in your entire
project across all the regions you don't
have to create separate template for a
different regions so in some sense it's
provide simplicity of management and
single single pane of control and
similarly there are some resources which
are region specific which are used by
all the zones in the region and they
follow a natural pattern like IP
addresses which are local to the region
which are which can be used within the
within the zones within the region and
this natural hierarchy of sharding of
the data model helps us achieve high
availability as we will talk about in
the rest of the presentation so some of
this will start to make a lot of sense
as we dive deeper into the rest of the
discussion so we could have chosen a
model we could have chosen a design to
have control plane sir out of a single
scope have everything be global with the
sarado global state database but as we
know that's a single point of failure
this could work as an improvement or the
previous design so what you see is each
individual scopes all the the scope data
model that I talked about resources that
are in the individual scope there serd
out of the individual control planes
however in this case we're sharing a
database that again is a single point of
failure one key point here that I talked
about from a topology standpoint we have
we have a front-end we have our Google
front-end which is nothing but a service
router and there is a second level of
router we have which which I've called
it here as API dispatcher and all it
does is it's a scope parser so you know
you are all paths all our resources are
scoped so you could reference
let's say a disc and a disc as we know
is a zonal scope so based on the
specific zonal scope that you're
interested in the right control plane
will be involved here it's important to
also call out that there is only one
singleton global scope and we serve 17
regions so there are 17 Global's 17
regional scopes and likewise there are
and I just made a very gross
generalization that there are free zones
per region so about 51 independent
control planes serving resources within
the scope so this is the final design
this is what we have in production this
is what we use we have independent
control plane with their own independent
databases so then the theme here is if
you want availability you need to
minimize shared point of failures so the
slide number one there's a single stack
which not gonna work for availability
second slide things are independent but
there is a shared database which again
reduces availability having independent
control stacks increases the aggregate
availability because there is no shared
fate between those stacks and that's
what we have zeroed in on that we are
not gonna have shared fate across
different stacks and have multiple
different stacks for different scopes
another key point that we felt was
sharing as we design our system what
about config and what about updating all
the scope control plane binaries the
model we have chosen is we have we do
multi-day face rollout and this is
largely to limit blast radius so there
are some config that needs to be rolled
out globally across all the control
plane that we serve and we do this in a
very staged fashion we have circuit
breakers along the way
and we do a lot of monitoring as we tear
the rollout so we watch rollout we do
zone by zone rollout and based on the
success we will take it forward and or
or some short peat at a time
the rollouts are completed and then you
get a new version of control plane and
if there are any config changes we do a
lot of upfront validation we are Sabri
cement testing and staging testing so
that's our design point number two let's
spend some time on something that we've
internally started to call rule of 9 and
what this simply stated assume your
chiness provide a service called service
a and it's serving a critical API this
could be your GC system serving create
instance API and service a is now
dependent on is built on a lot of
internal services we have identity as an
example an access check so a lot of
these underlying dependencies need to
offer at least an availability that is
higher than what I'm trying to provide
to our customers and you can imagine n
layer of dependencies and we'll go
higher at every layer below and that's
the rule of 9 so we followed this very
diligently by inspecting all the
difference across the board
so that's design point number three the
subsequent discussion I need to since
this talk is about distributed systems
and control plane serving control plane
availability let's spend a minute to
talk about CAF theorem so cap theorem
stated there are three key factors or
three key design consideration points in
any distributed system design so
distributed systems are partitioned by
nature so that's how much partition
tolerance you need to bear for your use
cases availability and consistency are
the other two parameters that you can
play with what cap theorem states that
you can pick only two of these and you
have to
you're probably trading off on the third
one and that's what ami intersects the
intersection of all three that's almost
an impossible thing to build so you
could either end up with a system that
is either consistent and available at
the same time that's typically all the
old-school single server model or more
than often in a distributed system
availability is extremely important
which has been the kind of choices that
we made for a lot of our design and we
picked AP AP based model in some cases
you might have consistency and partition
tolerance when if it's a shared global
object and and we'll talk about that
subsequently so here what I have an
example where we do some kind of lazy
state reconciliation so imagine there is
a critical API being served out of your
service and there is a dependency layer
below it you could pick a choice where
you fail close and you need to reconcile
the state synchronously in a partition
system
this can be tricky and for some cases we
felt instead of improving availability
we it was acceptable to just do a fail
open yes one example I'll bring up here
is in your application as well if you
have high availability for your API but
you have a dependency which is not a
critical dependency and you can live
with fail open semantics then you don't
have to force the rule of nine on the
dependency downstream for example let's
say logging you don't have to require
logging be have higher nines of
availability if we can reconcile build a
reconcile in your system that if logging
is not available you still continue and
reconcile later so that's some of the
pattern we have used for non-critical
dependency where we continue the
operation continue the top-level API
available and reconcile later so that's
our design point number four do a fail
open and do lazy reconciliation so in
some ways this is some sort of like an
eventual reconciliation let's talk a bit
about instance template remember in our
data model I talked about instance
template and snapshots or global
resources so what about them does that
pose a problem for GC system so I did a
deep dive on instance template yeah the
reason we want to talk about instance
template is earlier we showed you that
we have separate control stack for every
scope and there is a single global scope
so instance template our global
resources which is sort out of a single
stack so it's important for us to
explain why how we achieve high
availability for instance template and
snapshot so Rajesh is gonna talk about
that
so instance template is something that
gets configured so you so this is a
typical workflow of an instance template
you create an instance template it's a
global resource and typically manage
instance group depends on a referencing
an instance template and which is then
in turn used by VM creation within the
managed instance group so it's a it's a
global resource and it creates a global
dependency for something that is a
regional API or a zonal API this this
could be a problem and so how does auto
scaling or auto healing within the
context of a managed instance through
port so by the way there is a managed
instance group folks are doing a
presentation later today they will talk
a little bit in more detail about
regional scaling regional auto scaling
and regional orders
sorry regional management group what's
very key for both auto scaling and auto
healing you need to be able to create an
instances and reference your template so
the solution we have arrived we cache
instance template in all regions we
actually do two levels of caching the
intuition that we operated on is that it
was acceptable to go with eventual
consistency we are an AP based model so
we just talked about cap and this is the
AP model that we were we could
successfully apply for instance template
so the availability of instance template
is high because we cache it and what
that means is if a single global scope
or single global stack has a problem the
instance templates which are cached with
the regions and zone they're available
for order scaling and auto healing to
work
and there are more nuances to this that
and I'm not talking about all the use
cases so there are nuances off you're
trying to delete an instance template so
what what then and we can cover that if
there is interest later in the
presentation okay I built this twice my
apologies
so let's spend some a minute on snapshot
so snapshots is another global resource
snapshots are taken on your disk which
is a zonal resource so however there's
something that we did that we never
exposed to customers the underlying
snapshot has always been a multi
regional concept except the snapshot
resource itself the metadata has been a
global resource it's stored the GCS
buckets where the physical Ross
snapshots are stored it's a multi
regional concept yeah so this is
important if you have a zonal disc and
you take a snapshot you don't have to
worry about that zone not being
available and you're not being able to
access your snapshot so the metadata for
snapshot is global and it's available
while eventual consistency in all the
other regions the GCS bucket where the
snapshot data is stored that is multi
regional and that provides higher
availability for the actual snapshot
content and high availability for the
snapshot metadata so you can imagine a
scenario where your zonal stopped short
once the zone has trouble you can use
the snapshot and utilize that in some
other zone
so Vikas already covered this there's
another thing that we we announced that
GCP next war genome or which has been in
alpha in an alpha mode for some of our
customers we're now going to expose the
snapshot locality so as I told you the
underlying multi-regional locality will
get exposed there's a new parameter
we're exposing called storage locations
so you'll be able to learn where your
physical snapshots are getting stored
additionally we're gonna follow we're
gonna allow you providing choices for
where your snapshot will get stored so
this can be done on there on your
request body by specifying the month the
specific multi-regional place where you
need to get your snapshot stored if you
don't want us to choose or you could
specify specific regions so you could
have your source disk in us in any one
of the zonal us zones and you could pick
your regional destination to be in
Europe this is what it looks like that's
the parameter so I've given two examples
you storage locations with just one
location or you pick a multi regional
thing so the multi-regional is a GCS
construct EU simply implies we it's one
of the EU regions and you could as I
explained in the previous thing you
could spit we will tell you where what
are the specific multi-regional what's
the specific multi-regional places where
we place the snapshot so the design
point in both snapshot and instance
template that has worked for us is if
show consistency and UX so let's let's
take a moment and talk about the UX we
could have the choice we could have
taken is we could have
worded this into a regional resource we
could have deprecated our existing
global resource and offered regionally
coulomb's of those and we felt this is a
good user user convenience to a lot of
customers because oftentimes you try to
create a snapshot and make them
available in multiple regions and you're
going to end up doing the work yourself
so we just saving the burden by taking
on a lot of the complexity as part of
the DC system so the UX was a key point
so we didn't want to trade off on some
of the user user convenience meanwhile
we could achieve all the high
availability characteristics by
providing eventual consistency by
caching those resources in in each one
of the regions so that's our design
point number five so this is a this is a
recap of all the five design points we
covered and above all and most
importantly and it's an operational
point at Google most services we carry
out something we call dirt dirt is
disaster recovery and we simulate
failures we simulate region
unavailability we simulate latency and
we want to make sure our api's are well
behaving across all those failures that
could happen in real world and this
third exercise is invisible to the
customer we do it internally it's
planned and we prepare for it and we
want to see the system behavior when
disaster recovery is going on and this
does not impact any of the external VM
so an external tool in traffic so so far
we've discussed our data model and the
fact that our resources are either arts
our scope resources so either they're
zonal regional or global so
and you could use control plane to
provision your resources and you could
do this on demand in real time as you're
serving traffic or you could prefer
vision so let's apply some lessons so
there are two ways to approach this when
it comes to serving real-time traffic
for critical operations so let's imagine
you built a service
you built a GCE application that serves
thousand QPS and let's say you did one
of those good best design practices that
we advise on GCE and you leverage two
zones in this case us East 1a and US
East one be in my contrived example each
we M has been tested to serve 100 QPS
and they've been tested for that so you
have five VMs on the either side on two
zones isolated served by isolated
control planes and even the VMS are
completely isolated because there are
two different serving serving pads
imagine you lose one of the zones you're
gonna double the traffic on us east 1b
this may be not desirable because you
tested your service for 100 QPS so the
choices you have you would go on demand
ask for five more resources or five more
VMs
there is a possibility you may not get 5
VMs because we may stock out maybe us
West 1a is experiencing a zone wide
failure and every other customer is
trying to do the same thing that could
be problematic so so you could pre
provision in pre provisioning you will
you will configure you will pre
provision 5 more instances so here you
end up with 10 instances each and in
reality the traffic will look like this
in a steady state so you're serving half
what you tested for and that may be a
safe place to be and in the event you
lose his own you you would be safely
able to serve twice the amount of
traffic because that's what you test it
for so let's recap what we learned so if
you pre provision your give you're done
with the control plane configuring your
VMs the disks and and all the network
programming that goes with it and then
at that point your VM is serving live
traffic and we have it published SLA for
that and that that works out really well
so the pros are this pattern is
predictable it's simple
on the downside it costs a little bit
more and in a steady state or in the
average case your systems are less
utilized in the on-demand you put the
control plane on the critical path so
here you save on utilization and that's
an advantage that could work out for
some of your use cases but this is
unpredictable if it's a Black Friday you
could it you know you may not get your
instances
so the on-demand model is where if you
run into a problem in one of your zone
you try to allocate in other zones equal
number of VMs which you need and what
Rajat is pointing out it's not a
guaranteed unless they're reserved or
provision that you need X amount of VMs
you'll get X amount of VM it it could be
a stock or situation it could be a
thundering hold problem that the zone
you want
that's over capacity and nobody can get
extra VMs so that concludes our
presentations
[Music]
you